what drew you to anime over like
cartoons or other things like what drew
you to this medium specifically as a
child as a kid and growing up as well
for me it was just the fact that my mom
would just push it a lot because it was
the she knew that it was the easiest way
for me to appreciate the Japanese
culture every time I realized Joe is
born on Japanese speaking Japanese good
I like like my mom knew that like if I
just kept talking to her in Japanese
yeah it would most likely stick but she
wanted me to like not just be like
competent in Japanese like really the
whole cold chilly like yeah not just
appreciate the culture but also like
excel in Japanese yeah yeah yeah and
like thank God because now I think I
have yeah and like you know I have
learned to like appreciate the culture
and just anime in general and the
language and like I did like you know
learn [ __ ] out of Japanese even though
I said well in a lot of videos don't use
animate along Japanese yeah I kind of
helped open admit I learned a lot of
Japanese from watching out I mean any
amount of language that you take in to
learn like if you're watching anything
in a language it's good you know he'll
help I feel like as a kid you just
absorb it through osmosis or some like
oh yeah like I remember learning Thai
just because I was what like whenever
I'd go to Thailand I would just I would
just absorb it whenever I've solved my
family and we're just watching TV shows
did you learn any toy from the tide of
Zurich Anna coming hard in Thai it's
just very bad quality it's it's kind of
its kind of like I don't know there
wasn't a lot of money put into the
dubbing industry I reckon so I've still
not that much to do so and we all we all
know a second language then purely
because we were just raised yeah
everywhere is spoken yeah yeah but the
thing as well was when you were a kid
you know you have way more time to just
sit there and absorb it when you're an
and elitsa at ten minutes a day on
dueling or maybe right where's a kid
it's like eight hours of just you're
hearing this stuff so obviously you're
gonna pick it up I mean I was just like
that like from as far as I can remember
with my childhood like the only memories
I have is just like either watching
anime
reading manga or like watching cop right
right right yeah so already just from
that like two-thirds of my childhood
essentially is MIA just absorbing the
Japanese language in like anyway pause
right so I think that just helped me a
[ __ ] like if I never got into anime or
manga I would like to think that I would
be nowhere near as good write the
language as I am now I think definitely
for me when I was watching anime the
thing that appealed to me especially my
younger age is that like I said oh yeah
like there's more of a structure right
and there's always an overarching like
point there's only a journey to go on
and also I felt like you know I mean
this wasn't a problem back then and with
our cartoons you know the ones a week
were up with the part yeah I felt like
anime didn't treat the audience stupid
you know like I know if you're if you're
like 16 18 yeah you know if you don't
wanna watch Pokemon you can still
appreciate it and enjoy it and I felt
that like some cartoons I mean I mean
you can watch Samurai Jack any try this
time yeah there was a lot when I was
growing up they're very treated you as a
kid
right whereas Pokemon was like you're a
teenager you're going on a journey yeah
I'm gonna catch pokemon